If you think back to the last time you were
in pain, your reaction might have been something
like this.
*Bleep*
*Bleep* *Bleep*
Swearing in response to painful stimuli is
a pretty common human behaviour
but for a long time psychologists thought
it was a bad idea.
That swearing puts you in a negative state
of mind
and makes you think you're in a worse situation
than you actually are.
Something called - catastrophising.
To test this, back in 2009, researchers at
the university of Keele
came up with an experiment.
You fill up a bucket with ice cold water,
ask people to put their hands in it
and see how long they can withstand the pain.
Woookay.
We decided to re-create this experiment very
rigorously
with a self selecting sample of paid junkies
here at the Ri.
Woo!
In one condition you let the person use a
swearword.
Probably *bleep*.
It's probably *bleep*
*Bleep*
I'll probably go you *bleep*
And in the other they say a neutral word.
Wood.
Legs.
The authors hypothesized that swearing would
make the pain worse.
Because of the catastrophising effect.
But as you can see, what they found, was quite
the opposite.
I can't do it.
I can't.
*BLEEP* [Laughter off camera]
Flat. Flat. *Bleep*
*Bleep*
That was much worse.
Legs. Woah.
*Bleep*
Hard. *Bleep* Hard. Hard, hard, no.
[Laughter off camera]
Desk. *Bleep*
Desk.
So why does swearing help you withstand pain?
This is Dr Emma Byrne, a scientists and author
of the book
"Swearing is Good for You".
In the trial where they swear, they can keep
their hands in ice water
much longer, on average about half as long
again as when they're not swearing.
And what's more, afterwards when they're asked
how painful the ice water felt,
they will say that, actually while swearing
it feels less intense, it feels less painful.
It felt like it was the same amount of pain
but more manageable.
I say we should all swear all the time, sorry
mum.
In some follow up experiments the authors
found
that the effect still holds for people who
don't tend to swear much in daily life.
So what's going on here?
We know that swearing is a highly emotive
part of language.
There might be something emotional going on.
But we can also measure emotions outside of
the brain.
We can spot them in our physiology.
Your hands getting sweaty or your heart rate
rises.
And sure enough, when people are doing the
swearing condition,
if you measure things like their galvanic
skin response
or how sweaty their palms are getting.
Of if you measure their heart rate, you'll
see that they are
reacting physiologically to an emotional stimulus.
Far more than they are in the neutral condition.
One idea for why swearing helps with pain
is that
saying these emotionally charged words triggers
our fight or flight response,
hence the increased heart rate, by putting
us into a state a bit like aggression.
To explore this idea further, the same group
designed an experiment
to put people into a more aggressive state
by making them play
the first person shooter video game Medal
of Honor.
Compared with participants that played a golfing
game, Tiger Woods PGA Tour 07,
the first person shooters ranked more highly
on measures of aggression,
had higher heart rates and were able to withstand
the ice bucket experiment for longer.
Which seems to support the idea that something
like aggression
could be involved in easing the pain response.
But things aren't completely clear cut. In
another more recent study,
swearing was found to increase people's strength
and stamina on physical tasks.
But in this test, the authors didn't find
any
of the physiological responses associated
with fight or flight,
such as increased heart rate.
*Bleep*
They hypothesized that perhaps swearing acts
as a distraction
or maybe makes people feel less inhibited
and that's why their physical performance
increased.
For now, exactly why swearing has these effects
on pain tolerance and strength remains unknown.
Essentially *bleep* knows.
Hey guys, thanks for watching.
We tried something a bit new with this video
so let us know what you think in the comments
below.
Also, the Ri is now Patreon so if you like
what we do
and you want to support our work, then please
click the Patreon logo above.